yeah i farted on
unfortunately yeah it's tough the suit's
tight the harness squeezes it squeezes
your intestines yeah tom holland lets it
all out literally that's how convincing
my performance was the 25 year old actor
confesses to passing gas while filming a
swinging stun on the set of spider-man
no way home and get this the fart
happened on his co-star and girlfriend
zendaya did you fess up or did one of
them write you out no i fell obviously i
immediately was like i felt the rattle
sorry about that wow that's my bad
while appearing on siriusxm's town hall
to talk about their new film tom goes
into detail about the gassy moment which
also happened with co-star jacob batalon
yeah i just remember doing that stunt
and it was really difficult because i
obviously wanted to make sure that
you're in your hands and i didn't want
to like get it wrong and miss the wall
then you just clatter into the wall no
but i'm proud to say that you didn't do
it not because this would have happened
and we've all swung together we didn't
swing together yeah that's yeah that was
interesting
then came the stink bomb any injuries on
that one and he's slamming into walls on
that one three no injuries really no it
was actually just a fun little ride yeah
did you yeah i farted on me
unfortunately yeah it's tough the suit's
tight the harness squeezes it squeezes
your intestines now a stunt double could
have solved this problem but back in
2017 tom explained to e2 why it's
important for him to do his own
on-screen flips and tricks i would go as
far as they wanted me to go until they
would stop me you know there are some i
reckon i probably did like 75 to 80 of
all my stunts but
the 30 that isn't me i realize that's
the math is so wrong to what i just said
the ones i didn't know are the ones that
you go whoa holy that's amazing because
those are the crazy stunts that the
stunt guys did
it turns out zendaya wasn't bothered by
the stinky stun and why would she be
when she's in love of course hints of a
romance between the two swirled around
for years before they confirmed their
romance with speculation really heating
up this past july when tom and zendaya
were spotted kissing in a car what is it
like to know that you broke the internet
um those pictures of you and tom and
people were so excited because they're
like spiderman mj it's real like it was
like the world was rooting for this
moment well i'm i'm excited for the film
to come out i can't wait for everybody
to see um spiderman when it does come
out and you know we we all work so hard
we're all so you know we're all so close
from that and um yeah i mean i i i'm
excited we're gonna have a good press
tour i think and i'll probably see you
on that too tom also reflected on that
moment in a recent issue of gq he told
the mad quote one of the downsides of
our fame is that privacy isn't really in
our control anymore and a moment that
you think is between two people that
love each other very much is now a
moment that is shared with the entire
world